angela johnson is here angela i start
every podcast with a question that that
nor is always gets awkward which is why
i love it which is are we friends and
you have to answer
uh i like to think so but friends that
don't stay in touch that much is that a
thing that's
you
so we're family
yes we are family so our relationship
like i don't even know
because i was a fan of you before i met
you like you were already on mad tv i
think
yeah right yeah yeah like you were
already on tv like before i didn't like
see you in the hallways as a comic
before bad tv no yeah yeah and then
you know it's always uh who's that young
hawk bitch that has the job everyone
wants yeah and then
we met and i was like oh gosh she's like
nice and cool and smart and funny and
like a girl's girl and you know i feel
like when we first met
uh we definitely had a connection of
you're a girl i'm a girl we're in this
business together like let's help each
other out
um i remember and this is early on too
and i was just getting to know who you
were
and i would go to like all these general
meetings with like all these like
network executives and i thought like i
was doing a solid be like oh let me talk
about my friend whitney so they can know
about her too so be like oh yeah do you
guys know about whitney coming soon
hilarious they're like oh yeah of course
we do and i was like wait who's this
whitney that everybody already knows
about her by the time i might get into
all these offices yeah yeah we just
scammed her out of a lot of money we
know her yeah yeah we just we just gave
her a big deal and then told her she
wasn't allowed to say anything that um
uh she says oh shit we just gave her a
big deal and uh said please don't make
any jokes uh after we
paid you to be a comedian um but yeah
that was i was definitely uh yeah i
think that was definitely like the same
kind of time yeah and then and then i
have this thing and it's just it's my
shit
when someone gets married i'm like
like they don't they're go they're gone
like they're
been sent off on an iceberg
the way that
you never yeah like just like sort of
i'm not allowed to be in their life
their their spouse will never approve of
me hilarious they're doing that
and i i had two girlfriends do like
really aggressive interventions with me
because after they had kids i can't i
always assume as soon as a woman has a
kid she's busy she doesn't have time for
me i'm a drain uh-huh
i have to get the t-dap vaccine like i'm
like i'm just dirty
they don't let me laugh around their
kids i have to do tdap
what else they're like give a rabies
vaccine like no one wants me around
their kids without so many back seats
whitney you lick people's faces
they're
are you and like your hair dye does it
like come off like we can't
yeah like no one wants me so i just
always am like i'm just going to leave
them alone because
as someone that used to codependently
say yes to things i didn't want to do
because i thought i had to add an
obligation i project that on to other
people whereas
mature adults new moms aren't going to
be like yeah let's hang out unless they
mean it they'll go no i can't yeah but
i'm like i don't want to overload this
person which is probably also me being
overloaded and assuming everybody else
is like
puts as much on their plate as i do i
used to do that too i would
self-sabotage my friendships once my
friend got married or had a baby
and my best friend called me on it when
it happened because as soon as she got
engaged i started pulling away and i
started making this other person my best
friend i was like oh i'm gonna go hang
out with her oh we're gonna go do this
and that and it was like subconsciously
but i was still like i was hurt that
you're leaving me i feel amazing and
then yeah i feel abandoned so i was like
okay then i'm gonna abandon you yeah i
have a new baby you can't fire me yes i
could
which the irony is it's like because
your guy's probably not gonna like me
because i'm like the single girl but the
irony is he's not gonna like me because
i'm hurting you and he's gonna be like
why is she doing that yeah
you know what i mean it's like you're
creating the exact thing
that i am yeah that's so easy she called
me out on it and i didn't realize it
until she said it i was like oh
yeah i am doing that i'm sorry like yeah
my bad and i my therapist even had to
say to me because i was like well my
best friend dory just had a kid and
jenny had a kid so now i'm just like
alone and they abandoned me forever and
and she was like have you haven't seen
them and i'm like well no they have
babies like i don't know like as if
their tits are exploded like if they
can't
like
like she's like how do you think child
rearing works they're sitting there
bored out of their minds with something
that's asleep most of the time like like
the best thing you can do is give them
an opportunity to hang out with an adult
because they're just staring at this
blob that won't even remember anything
they're saying that's shitting all over
everything they care about like the best
thing they could have is their friend
who's a comedian next to them just
making them laugh right and i was like
what so
it it it's taken me a long time to not
um
decide that someone is rejecting me sure
and then be like well fine i'll just
which is my shit of just like trying to
not get hurt i mean i did that my whole
career starting out as a stand-up going
to the comedy clubs yeah that's why you
never saw me there i didn't hang out
with a comedy store i didn't hang out at
the improv and hang out at any of the
clubs
because good childhood we get it your
parents loved you we got it
i would project on to everyone that they
didn't like me because i blew up so fast
and also by the way
i'm not saying that's true but that
could have that's also not always untrue
yeah even though
it's obviously jealousy and a compliment
it still is like these are my co-workers
these are my peers and i feel bad
walking in a space with all this success
because i'm like accidentally making
people feel bad about themselves because
they're going to compare themselves
that's just the nature of it yeah and so
by doing that i
also want to say yeah she got success
really fast because guess what we had
women had to we had to move really fast
because we expired 40 yeah we had like
40 less years to get this done right
it was like you can't be on tv after 30.
so we had to get successful at 25 it was
our only window back then totally and it
was like uh i would project that onto
people but then also that would keep me
from making relationships like actual
friends and i remember i would like
watch like you and you'd be up at the
club like all the time and eliza would
be able to club all the time and i'd be
like i wish i could just do that and
every time i had a set at the improv or
wherever and it was like okay wednesday
sure girl i was thinking about for like
three days until i got there
and it was like diarrhea the whole time
i was there i'm like okay let me know
why people didn't talk to you yeah
what's that yeah exactly
all the things i was so
nervous i had so much anxiety and i was
like oh my god this is not worth it and
i remember telling my manager at the
time like should i be forcing myself to
go hang out at the clubs and like make
relationships and he was like no why
like
they're wanting where you're at right
now so just go be where you're at right
now yeah and i was like but then the
irony is you want to be one of them yes
yeah but i like community though like
but i want like peers i want to like
be chummy with people and i remember
watching the um the documentary the
comedy store documentary and i remember
feeling like so sad
that i let my oh god i'm getting
emotional sorry about that um
god
did i let my anxiety win for all those
years
and i robbed myself of like making
relationships with people because at the
end of the day that's what it's about is
relationships not like our careers and
what are you doing what are you booking
but it's like relationship and i
remember seeing that in the documentary
the community
and people like um
bonding and things like that i was like
oh man i robbed myself of that because i
let my anxiety win for all those years
but
you didn't have to see any dicks you
want didn't you know
so
so i
can we if she wants a tissue can we get
one if we have something um this is so
effing touching because i went the other
way
whereas
you know when i i'm the first person to
say
i'm so grateful for all the people that
hurt me i you made me stronger all the
people that hated me all the people that
emotionally abused me even down to
physical abuse i'm at the point where
i'm like you i am invincible and and
you hurting me because i know hurt
people hurt people and i know that if
you hurt me
like something terrible happened to you
if you're sadistic like that or you're
mentally ill or a sociopath or something
like i can defend anyone
that did damage to me now
39 years old um
but at the time it was a very dangerous
place for me and i forced myself to go
and i shouldn't have like i think we
both went extreme ways i was like i am
gonna fucking show you yeah that i can
take all this abuse yeah i can it and it
was really unhealthy for me because a
comedy club which
no
no criticism it comedians
have uh i don't want to say all
comedians are crazy or sick or whatever
but
you know we uh we obviously
crave
validation from drunk strangers
and destroy our lives to chase that and
self-harm and self-flagellate in a lot
of ways and that often
comes out in a way that we don't always
play well with others and we hurt other
people and sometimes we think we're play
fighting but it's not
um
you know
some of us are masochists sadistic
whatever it was that group of people at
that time
and the
type of people that were attracted to
that hallway
were really dangerous for me and gave me
really bad data whereas i was working on
not all men cheat
and then
i'm just looking yeah for six hours in
that hallway watching men cheat yeah
yeah you know what i mean people whose
wives i know yeah so it's like it's i i
it definitely stunted a lot of my growth
and made me hold on to a lot of old
stories
that i needed to be debunking i probably
needed to be doing more what you were
doing
hanging out with mary your friends were
getting married and seeing like what was
possible yeah because but it was to me
because of growing up in alcoholic home
with so much um
you know
pugnacious behavior confrontational
behavior scandalous behavior there were
always fights breaking out there was
always like someone getting hurt someone
getting shot i mean it was k like i
craved that because that's what my
evenings were like when i was a kid
that's my comfort zone it's like it's
midnight like it's too quiet
yeah because i was so addicted to
adrenaline and drama so had you felt
comfortable there
your parents oh you would have would owe
you
would have to hit your venmo you know so
the kind of people that felt comfortable
there not judging them it's just
we um
felt calm in crisis chaos common chaos
yeah yeah and the kind of people that
would go there and go i don't i feel
don't feel comfortable i'm like stick to
that instinct you know because i think
that i thought that i had to endure a
lot of emotional pain discomfort
physical pain i mean i would stay till
two in the morning just to prove that i
wasn't a girl like i could hang with the
guys
like i'm sleeping four hours because i
have to work other jobs to make money
you know and
i was it was masochistic on my part
because i was trying so hard to neuter
myself and show guys that i could hang
or just be around guys and not ever date
them so everyone knew like i don't date
comics
like i'm one of you and
you know and at the time the way that
the comedy store was set up was was kind
of toxic
uh which is that you know one of the
managers it was you had to put it you
had to show your loyalty to that place
and you had to have no life so i didn't
get to date i didn't get to have
girlfriends i didn't get to have friends
i just was like putting myself going
like
i'm not fucking going anywhere and
i'm going to and that's how you like
earn some respect but it's a sick kind
of like
you like it's like unnecessary like hell
weak navy seal shit where it's just like
this is just like hazing and you know
right but it also
you know yeah and i and i go yeah i rob
myself of girl friendships i rob myself
of like traveling you know like all that
stuff but i'm like i just feel like
we're just getting good and like the
best is yet to come come on say it
whitney you preach this don't you think
it's like our 20s is such a wash like
i'm glad we were hustling i'm glad we
were like
no no one in their 20s had their shit
together back then yeah you didn't need
to have all those girlfriendships would
have been a disaster yeah it just breaks
my heart to hear but it would have broke
my heart more
if you were like
yeah i used to hang out and
had a lot of dicks hit me in the chin
didn't want to hit you in the gym
right right so cause i it's also so
weird to hear someone else's side
because i just saw you was like so
focused and so together
and so like yeah i don't need to deal
with that i'm doing this
and i would we would talk about you
could be like does she just work out new
stuff like on the road
like how does she do that
that's funny i've always wondered like i
wonder what people think about me but
yeah that's what i would do i would just
write my jokes on the road i don't have
the bravery to do it i didn't want to go
i have to go try it 50 times at a
fucking sushi restaurant in santa monica
at some open mic before i'll do it
because i'm insecure so we're always
just going like damn she's secure like
she likes herself that's how that's what
we're all trying to do thank you thank
you you know so what do you feel a lot
better about my choices thank you yeah
also
and the other thing is like yes i mean i
mean having
dealt with so much
negativity from my own comedy community
and and having it really break my heart
you know it's like comedians are
professional complainers like if if you
weren't successful they'd have a problem
with you if you're too successful they
have a problem with you if you're a
woman if you're not a woman it's like
comedians it's like i always say about
like
we complain about sugar cookies and hot
pockets
i mean you know what i'm saying there's
nothing comedians will not
find a problem with yeah yeah
like that's our job to find problems
yeah
literally and yeah i always point to
gary goldman i'm like gary goldman in
his new special or his new hour has 20
minutes just on mangoes
and how do they have a low yield of
fruit and like how dare they
have such a big pit so it's like
trying to say he also writes on the road
yeah yes yeah fuckers
um but uh but so yeah so it's like you
know insecure people are dangerous and
we're a very insecure sort of group and
you also seem very self-contained and
this is also something i'd love to talk
about because you know you're um
you know
you have a very like strong connection
to your religion
and there's a it
you don't come off like you need
people's approval and that's a little
bit annoying to a comedian or to
insecure people because we want to go
how can i like
like put my hooks in you like back then
i was really only in relationships with
people that i could like rescue or fix
because i like thought that was a thing
and i i only could have self-esteem
through being needed
and i didn't think anyone would that was
self-contained sure and had their
internal needs met
uh
would want to be would
what do they need from me then what are
they well how am i gonna keep them yeah
now i'm gonna get abandoned so i need
someone that's like gets addicted to my
help or that i stick my you know um it
has to be codependent and entrenched or
else they can leave it anytime yeah and
you were kind of like
like
too healthy
there's no like in
but can you talk a little bit about like
was has have you always had a strong
relationship with uh christianity and
was that did that help you through like
what helped you get to a point to this
i'm so grateful
for
my
years of being super devoted christian
committed to
the the plan that i had for myself i'm
grateful for those years
and i'll i'll talk about that and um
but also where i'm at now is definitely
an evolved version of myself and in my
20s who still loves god who still
says in jesus name amen and but now also
says thank you divine thank you love you
guys
so i feel like i have gone through
probably the past five years uh
deconstruction of my christianity
that i held on so tightly in my early
20s for sure and i think the fact that i
held on to that probably saved me from a
lot of uh complications and heartbreaks
that i would have got myself into
uh bad decisions i would have made
um
and at the same time because of that i i
made some decisions
that i feel like robbed me of certain
things like saying no to certain like
movies that i thought was like oh as a
christian i probably shouldn't do this
because it had like one dick joke in it
and i was like oh that's probably
i shouldn't do that and then the movie
comes out and it's actually not that at
all and i just said no because i was
trying to be super christian you know
what i mean
and so there is like things i would want
you to get the money you get it all you
know what i'm saying like i don't think
god cares one chapter it's just all
decks
you know why didn't i think about it
i didn't need you see
um but yeah so i've gone through a whole
journey but during that time uh starting
out in stand-up i was definitely uh
super devoted super
uh into my my prayer time my devotional
time my staying connected with my
community to make sure like i'm staying
on top of things and but this is mental
health whether it's whatever you're
really everyone's got their religion
whether it's it's even people are like i
don't believe in god i'm like uh but you
go to berry's boot camp every single
morning you have a religion yeah yeah
his name is
it does the same thing do you know what
i'm saying like because you know
religion over time has been you know
justified to do incorrigible things and
start wars but everyone's got their
religion growing up and in my 20s i
definitely had my the christian route
this is how you pray these are the words
that you say when you go to church
there's tithe and offering and then
there's praise and worship and then
there's all the things like this is how
there's wine at church this is how you
worship god like this is how you do it
yeah and that was the only way to do it
and now i'm at a place where it kind of
like what you're saying like i'll wake
up in the morning and i'll do like my
yoga stretches my energy medicine and
i'm doing all my tapping and like all
the things and i'm praying and i was
like yes god what's the topic so like
kind of
like learning about energy tap dancing
um
having
learned about um energy medicine
and
learning about just frequencies and also
i stand in the dirt
and to get the grounding and the
electricity but you're talking to the
right bitch
but that's what i'm saying it doesn't
sound crazy enough to me yet i wasn't
this girl though yeah like i i was the
girl that was like oh that's crazy like
just just talk to jesus that's all you
need to do yeah yeah but now i have such
a connection with mother earth that i do
enjoy going out jesus was barefoot to
get the electricity from them
he was grounding
he was he was so that's that's kind of
where i'm at now so it was it's but i
it's how do we know if we don't know
it's like we have to get we we get
programmed and then we de-program and
it's the whole deal with 12-step
programs is take what you like and leave
the rest just take what works for you
like customize what works for you there
are times i mean i always say like
i want to say like i don't believe in
like a god in the sky that like you talk
to but when shit hits the fan you better
believe i'm like god yeah god uh and
then you know that i on some level
believe because that's the when shit
really hits the fan yeah that's who i go
to even though it's just talking to
yourself or whatever it is
but i always i always open with
sorry it's been a while
and that's where you know on some level
i think that he's keeping score i'm
apologizing to this thing that i'm
saying doesn't exist so yeah whether
that's my old programming or whatever
but on some level i think when shit hits
the fan
it probably is old programming i deal
with that even deconstructing from
christianity because we're taught don't
pick and choose what you want to believe
you believe the whole thing
at all oh wow yeah so if anybody who is
christian and deconstructing from their
faith meaning they're figuring out what
their faith is what they subscribe to
what they don't subscribe to what
they're like oh actually i don't think
that was right i think we got that one
wrong you know anybody who's doing that
work it's really brave work especially
if you've been programmed in that
religion your whole life yeah to now say
i don't know like what do you mean gays
are bad they don't get to go to heaven
or hell yeah wait hold on there's heaven
or hell like let's talk about that first
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so there was a
lot of things that i was like those are
two gay clubs actually that are really
fun
so guess what
let's go i'm just saying i said jesus on
that cross
if you guys don't want gays then why is
like jesus the cutie
why is he such a daddy
with a beard in that box okay
it's it's brave work for anybody
deconstructing and
just reconstructing what their faith is
and the shame part so it's like the
whole thing is it's religion
christianity catholicism we do have to
deal with the fact that it is a business
and was a business and the more you sin
the more money you paid and you were
absolved understand by paying money so
like if you're a good businessman you're
gonna go oh the more things that are
carnal
that are enjoyable that we make sins the
more money we're gonna make like that's
just good business you know and every
you know i think community or movement
or that has the best of intentions power
corrupts and greed takes over right and
that's human nature so it's like bikram
yoga the bikram yoga guy is a scumbag
you know the osho cult like
it's tragic because it's they're preying
on the very people that are just trying
to do the right thing yeah and
then
it gets caught up in the guilt and the
shame thing and as someone that i was
like oh
religion just said you're a woman so you
were just born bad
you make men you're why men
get distracted and want to have sex with
you all like it's your fault yeah yeah
um
you are impure
uh you can't masturbate
um you know just
you're just bad you're born bad you're
that the whole thing is original sin
you're born dirty so it's like
to go okay
there's a lot of things that work for me
about this but like that shame stuff
because the engine of addiction is shame
so all of like
my acting out behaviors
was oh i feel ashamed now i need to
self-medicate with this or i need to you
know disassociate with this and then so
i had to really step away from organized
religion because i was like this shame
thing is what yeah it's shame drives
like pedophilia yeah you know what i'm
saying and her people so as long as you
can't say hey i did something bad and
people go like it's all good me too
instead of your like yeah
i needed to be able to be human
and i couldn't
i didn't feel like the rigidity of that
allowed it but now i feel like i can go
back and go you know what i kind of like
that yeah maybe
maybe don't sleep with your friend's
neighbor yeah
what is it
with your neighbor's wife
points in there
there's some good points in there i like
this
but also like
yeah and then it's also just i
definitely think for a while
you know
if someone had a strong religion i was
like they're not gonna right right right
i'm just gonna feel i'm gonna ruin their
relationship with god
god's not gonna like them as much so i
should just stay away from them and i
was i was also mentioning to a friend
too like
back in those days exactly what you just
said oh she's super religious she's not
gonna be down with me
i feel like i came across that a lot and
then i would notice people would
wouldn't be themselves around me yeah
they would hold back
um there would be you know the
conversations that they were like oh we
just would think you wouldn't want to be
involved in this type of conversation
and the sad part is probably at the time
i probably wouldn't have wanted those
conversations and now
i'm at a place in my life where i can
just have the most honest real
conversations with my friends and they
know there's no judgment coming from
jesus did hang out with prostitutes sure
did so i feel like you could have hung
out with me
we would have been okay we now take a
break in two women yapping
to talk about
what you probably
need
to be able to
hear my opinions for this long
gummies
diet smoke gummies they deliver the
perfect medium high they're not light
they're just right because you know the
problem with wheat edibles
yeah yes
i do
almost ruined my life
you get way too high maybe we just scale
it back sail back maybe scale it back
yeah take one of these edibles and watch
yellow jackets yeah
legal thc ships to most states check out
dietsmoke.com to make sure they ship to
you organic and all natural each diet
smoked gummy is infused with 10
milligrams of thc derived from american
grown hemp if they don't ship to you
move satisfaction guaranteed diet smoke
is so confident that you'll get their
perfect medium high with their products
they'll refund your money if you're not
100 satisfied can i tell you i took
these gummies with crystal smith when we
were writing for the josh richards roast
it just took away the fear and the
anxiety that makes me go oh that's not
funny don't take that risk or like i was
like energized and clear and like
running a writer's room it's a medium
high when cbd isn't enough and bond
grips are too much
when they make your house smell like
shit you can't rip a bonk during work
enjoy the smooth relaxing high of diet
smoke right now diet smoking when you're
on a plane and you checked your bong
[Laughter]
diet smoke is here to help
they're offering and they did you solid
by making the packaging look like mints
thanks diet smoke thanks diet smoke
right now diet smoke is offering our
listeners an incredible discount when
you go to dietsmunk.com and use promo
code whitney you'll get 20 off all their
delta h thc gummies go to dietsmonk.com
promo code whitney to get 20 off that's
diet smoke.com promo code whitney for 20
off diet smoke thc you like diet coke
you're gonna love diet smoke
this podcast is sponsored by better help
as if you didn't know
by listening for just one minute oh
because i when i i meet our fans of this
podcast and
they are have their shit together the
only problem a lot of them have is not
knowing how much their shit is together
you know what i'm saying there are those
who can't teach
how dare you be for yourself um and so i
see where a podcast where we end up
talking about a lot of mental health
stuff hopefully in a funny way most of
the time um
the kind of people
are seekers you know but i think it's
important that that for people that talk
about getting help in therapy also go
and if you want to do that too because
we're always seeking and there's always
more to do on ourselves regardless of
how perfect you are except for emily who
is cooked
do not change anything don't change a
thing better help will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not self-help it is
professional therapy done securely
online you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy you can sit in your
own uncomfortable chair you bought for
yourself because you have low
self-esteem special offer for good free
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney
speaking of whitney
my favorite segue
where are you going to be going to be in
grand rapids michigan um because that's
what stars do
and that's where they go
i'm going to be at the glc live no one
knows what that stands for at so
baby this is a typo
you typo
glc live at 20 monroe there's no way
that's the name of the venue um this is
kind of like how i pushed the miami show
for six months and it was miami oklahoma
and not florida and we sold no tickets
because i would like to say once
i'm coming to my house hey hey bring
your sweatshirts back it was like
like
like
hot take i i don't google myself who
knew uh march 18th am i going to be
screwing around
in la
enjoying my life nope building a
relationship with the wonderful man that
i keep sabotaging a future with am i
going to be
trying to have biological kids
since that window is very quickly
closing i think it's a door but you know
what i mean it's a swinging door okay
it's a window which i'm gonna jump out
of it if i have to it's a jail cell i'm
not gonna be doing any of that mind me
taking care of myself training this new
puppy that has the ability to
kill a human whenever it wants in five
years no no no i'm gonna be in portland
maine
which should not be abbreviated as m-e
but now is not the time to get into that
i can't deal with your shitty acronym
right now portland me
portland maine shouldn't it be portland
m.a but that's massachusetts it's a
slippery slope but massachusetts should
be ms that's mississippi
huh
mississippi should be why can't it be m
i s michigan mi it's michigan and then
viewing michigan and
yeah it's it's a slippery slope y'all
have been put to the bottom of the
barrel and i think that's fucked up you
maine wasn't maine
discovered way before those states or
made up
you know i'm right we took it a lot
earlier colonies was maine one of them
so you're letting mississippi michigan
right all these fucking states that came
after you take the best acronyms i was a
history major was maine one of the no
it doesn't seem like it wasn't one of
the original also
maps are all wrong by the way fyi
there's no way any maps are correct
that's a side conversation number two
we have a lot to get back to hold on
number two merrill auditorium march 18th
number two portland maine well it's
obviously a port city so it probably was
being used in some capacity maybe it was
owned by canada or something if only
there was a machine where we could get
all the stations if only there was a
duck duck go um
portland maine
i just feel like
as someone that has an email
that's my name
and then a number mm-hmm
yeah maine wasn't this is like this is
like being emily6 at gmail.com emily
noonan6 at gmail.com guess what i'm was
almost about to say my email
i totally almost said i was like because
someone thought you know i had to
abbreviate it because someone emily
noonan is a physical therapist in san
francisco oh by the way i do have an
email for you about your vacation to
sage else i will forward it along
also i need your services
please you're also going to have some
money you spend most of your time trying
to go to a physical therapy yeah she's a
physical therapist
isn't that funny
emily noonan gmail.com and you are a
you need a physical touch
march 19th if you're still listening
which i'd lose respect for you if you
were
laconia new hampshire colonial theater
uh let's colonize the colonial theater
together now new hampshire was one of
the original 13 colonies
okay but not mean okay new haven
connecticut i'm coming to the college
street music hall or is it collage are
we sure it's college
are we sure it's not that
i'm sorry puppy i would be collage
how do you spell collage
c-o-l-l-a-g-e oh see that's
that's awesome that's why we have emily
on board here
she's a human autocorrect
march 26 will be in albany
new york at the egg
remember when we used to carry eggs
around like as kids because they're like
this is what's gonna be like to carry a
baby
traumatic
april first austin texas yes we'll be at
the paramount theater april 2nd dallas
texas majestic theater
uh last couple times i did uh those
venues at least before the pandemic was
house of blue so i'm very excited to be
um performing in some of these uh venues
that um
look it's a dream it's a dream in a life
that's one nightmare after another i
finally get to have a dream while i'm
awake hometown show may 20th i'm gonna
be in tyson's corner capital one hall
the name of a bank that i probably owe
money to or wouldn't give me a loan
solely based on um my brand toronto show
there's a new date because we had to
cancel it because of the pandemic i'll
be the danforth music hall hey sorry
this puppy is biting oh he's on fire i
know well he's mouthing and he's
teething but i love you guys yeah and
you guys come first always as i'm just
bleeding from the face
for so many reasons back to our guests
who
um
frankly
didn't know what they got themselves
into
what is in your writer i've never asked
to comic this so your manager's here so
you're not gonna lie to me
i um
it's changed over the years i'll tell
you what it used to be back in the day
because that's a bible
no yeah
um so i would have a blanket okay and a
pillow michael jackson writer son
uh no just a full fuzzy
nice little
because she because you like to nap
before the shows
so my um anxiety would manifest itself
in a few ways one is i would get really
cold so i always needed a blanket two i
would get really tired i would start
yawning yeah
and so i was like give me a pillow so i
can lay down i'm gonna turn the lights
i'm gonna take a nap in between shows
like whatever it is
and um
it wasn't until years later that i
realized that that was signs of my
anxiety until i started getting my
anxiety in check then i didn't need the
blanket anymore i didn't need to i
wasn't tired yeah i'm fine yeah but my
anxiety is shutting my body down so once
i learned that i got rid of those things
on my writer and i used to have things
like um pepto-bismol
diarrhea
like all the things
but now it's really just like
um fruits and veggies
uh cause trying to be healthy in a
comedy club is hard to do i mean i have
the fruits and veggies always there but
i still order the fries number one thing
i i only think i ate uh for
um
god eight years
comedy club what to always ordered a
comedy club
baked potato baked it's the only safe
thing
one i would own it would always be three
baked potatoes
i would i would take one back so tell me
the only way to like not for sure not
get food poisoning in st louis
for because i would always be like i'll
have the cobb salad you're like no like
just and it's and most comedy club food
now is actually too good i have some
notes about the improv actually because
i'm like people are actually eating
focus on the show like the food is now
like good it's trite yeah i'm like i
know i'm like what the fuck is that like
there's like buffalo cauliflower things
now and i'm like this is no one's gonna
be listening to the company like just
the food has to be a little worse
um for these jokes to hit better um
but
i would love to uh uh talk about your
anxiety it's something that i have said
before on the show because you know like
a little anxiety is sometimes just our
body giving us information and i think
that sometimes you know because there's
anxiety there's the kind that's a dis
there's a difference between
being depressed and having depression
you know and if it's chronic and
constant if you're anxious for a job
interview
once or twice that's normal you should
have that yes but if this is something
that is making your life unmanageable
because i think a lot of people now
young people believe they should never
have anxiety ever and it's like i got
anxious i was like what happened i was
like well i was about to go give a
speech at the school play yeah that's
normal yeah yeah you don't need to be on
medication yet
that's a good sign yeah that means
you're not as a psychopath or
sociopathic this is good you know i felt
like i started shifting my relationship
with my anxiety
to um
recognizing and instead of like
i hate you yeah
but showing gratitude and be like okay
it's your body trying to protect you
thank you so much um for trying to
protect me and for all this diarrhea i
really appreciate it yeah from this
weekend of shows that i'm about to go do
but honestly
like i'm good you're gonna be fine you
just go for three days and you come
right back and i start doing self-talk
to myself
and i started doing um i would get
anxiety like
if i had two weeks off before i had to
go hit the road again it wasn't really
two weeks off it was two weeks of
anxiety about when i have to go back
so then i started uh shifting that to
when the anxiety would come up i would
recognize it and i would say hey
um
i i'm gonna let you feel your feels like
you can feel that anxiety but we're not
gonna feel it until maybe a day or two
before we have to leave huge so i'm
going to give myself these next 10 days
to just be easy and it's amazing how
that would just calm myself down because
i wasn't saying you don't get to feel
this no i was saying you can feel this
but not yet scheduling it i have to be
followed up with so many times just hey
do you want to perform at this casino or
not you avoid girl until they're like
we're pat because but here's the thing
this is this is my shit i love this
because
the app
not giving an answer is an answer
over time in the abs so if i have if i
haven't said yes for three days the
answer is no you know what i mean but
it's not i i
i'll go let's if it's meant to be the
last again like yeah
because i want to avoid making the
commitment that's what it's commitment
issues like i have full-on commitment
issues yes because i have i also have
i'm going broke issues so like i'm
always going broke
by scarcity complex but then i'm like i
can't commit to making money so i'm
sorry
totally yeah because i'm like okay
that's all the way in september
it's in my two weeks that i have been
committed in september listen
i don't know what september is gonna be
like if i
if i take this date in september i'm
telling the universe i won't have a tv
show by then yeah and i'm saying i'm i'm
already have failed at my nine other
dreams incredibly acknowledging i've
been like well i don't know if i want to
do that because that's when like pilot
season is february
and then there's up front so make sure i
don't have any shows for updates
and i'm planning for upfront and by the
way and you know the more shows you book
the more people are gonna want you
because you're unavailable and it's just
like and as soon as you stop needing the
business because you already have your
own empire going that's when they want
you ironically right right so it's just
like it's it's like if you want to book
a job i mean i started doing this when i
was 25 or 26
it was before because emily was my
assistant first now she's my boss but
this was before i um we did um peels
together and we're both molting we're
both peeling off
slopping i see
i'm collecting it
sheets are coming off your face like a
pastry just
she can't even smile all the way it's
like some nice fresh parm
salad
we did it's kool-aid or whatever it is
fried our faces and i don't think we
understood the down time it's gonna be
this bad i mean you it is don't don't
peel it but you i do see
like blotches
can you just not put your face near the
wall
but yeah i'm sitting here and i'll just
like look down i'm like oh look i mean
it's just getting skin is coming up and
these are really good cameras so they
definitely are okay
i know this is we're not rolling on me
at all we're gonna put my robot in later
and edit around it in post i just
realized the time where i think
comedians really got jealous of you the
irony is what you did alvin and the
chipmunks really
it's it's so crazy to say that out loud
now
people like oh man she's in the album
the chipmunks movie fuck man like
it's such a it's just it's just so funny
to me i remember the billboards were
everywhere and i was like oh man she's
winning win and winning and it's just
like it's an amazing thing to be apart
but it's just so funny just
how absurd
yeah jealousy
is yeah it definitely is and it's it's
the um she's over there trying to
entertain kids fuck her
i hate her
it's like i mean you know with the
horses and they put the blinders on so
you just stay focused on your lane it's
that kind of thing even with this
journey and i've had to remind myself
many times in
especially with social media
being able to see my peers and what
they're doing and so it's one thing like
when you're riding high
you can still compare yourself to
somebody else who's also writing high
and being like should i be doing that
though should i be directing too like
maybe i should go um
go shadow a director i don't want to be
a director why would i want to do that
just because i saw my friend doing that
now i should go try to be a director
like all of these things be like no just
like stay focused in your own lane and
um because they were probably directing
because they couldn't do stand up do you
know what i mean it's also like we and
we forget that like
the world needs contrast but i think
that this a lot of comedians because we
had to take matters in our own hands i
started writing for myself because i
wasn't getting jobs because i was too
loud i was too shrill i wasn't the girl
next door i you know like i didn't i
would always come in second um
uh so
oh yeah so being an extra was that
were you like i know i'm gonna
have my own show were you like i'm i'm
researching this yeah um so i basically
got to take free class from jennifer
aniston lisa kudrow courtney cox david
tremor mountain block matthew perry
because i was an extra on friends for
season 9 and 10. that was my very first
job in the entertainment industry i had
just moved here after the super bowl
because i was cheerleader for the
oakland raiders the only reason why i
even tried out for the oakland raiders
was because i wanted it to be my sign if
i should pursue the entertainment
industry or not
so i went i auditioned i made the squad
i did it for one year we went to the
super bowl that year came home from the
super bowl packed up my station wagon
and i drove to la went to super bowl
largely because
of the motivation
given by the cheerleader
yeah
which i'm gonna say something because i
have i've had monica aldama on the show
uh who is the head coach for navero
cheer right she's a really good friend
of mine i'm obsessed with it i used to
because i was a basketball player and
was jealous of the cheerleaders and
when i was at the school that had
cheerleaders in virginia it was very
much like very toxic feminine it was
like be aggressive and we're like thank
you we got it we know thank you so much
like you know it was like they had the
bows and we were kind of the
like
tomboys the
athlete the football players didn't like
you know what i mean and so it was like
we were really pitted against
cheerleaders and then over the pandemic
i watched like i always just like i used
to have jokes about you know
cheerleaders in my act i made my first
special sports perfect example football
you guys are watching football and
you've got these amazing athletes on the
field doing amazing things incredible
they're flying they're doing phenomenal
things not enough for you you still need
whores around the perimeter
of the field
god forbid there'll be two seconds
without a tit in the background of
something you're watching
she really just cracked me up man so
funny to me because that's so obviously
a guy's idea you know like a guy
obviously thought of that because the
cheerleaders still cheer even when their
team is fucking losing they cheer no
real woman would ever act like that if
her man was out on the field for five
hours on a sunday
bombing she wouldn't be like go baby go
go she'd be like jason we're leaving and
uh
and i watched i was like holy shit
i am so ignorant about this this is the
most badass this is the most impressive
shit yeah i've
of any sport and i've been i grew up
doing that cheerleading my whole life i
did competitive tumbling stunts
cheerleading so i didn't want to
audition for the raiderettes because
that wasn't my style that was well also
here's what my point is why aren't
cheerleaders getting paid more i was
when the when that chiefs game happened
i um
tweeted i was like go chiefs now let's
change the name and let's let's pay the
cheerleaders like that like why aren't
navero cheerleaders leaving that and
then going and doing getting paid a good
amount of money to be
because it's like they're not going to
attract the kind of people that are
going to do that if they don't start
paying right this whole not paying the
cheerleaders thing is just wild to me
yeah and they're not even allowed to
cavort with the players yeah and that
would be the only other reason to
fucking do it yeah was to get that sperm
in you
know what i'm saying because isn't that
a rule oh yeah there's no fraternization
between players and cheerleaders and
coaching staff um but the interesting
thing at the time was uh the raider the
raiderettes were the highest paid
cheerleaders in the nfl at 85 a game
was sick
doesn't that not include practice oh we
don't get paid for practices only game
day we have practices three days a week
um
and you have to have another job oh yes
not a job this is a hobby
you have to have a job 85 a game and you
don't get paid till the end of the
season and you don't even get to meet
the players or the coaches or the owners
so you're not supposed to
um
what's interesting is at the time the
oakland raiders was the only
organization that didn't have the rule
of no fraternization between players and
cheerleaders oh you chose wise but it
was still
frowned upon okay so when i remember
when i first joined this christianity
i've been frowned upon i need your help
i'm like i got it i'll
but they we had to do etiquette classes
we had to do all kinds of things for the
raider and they told us like there's no
friends between players and cheerleaders
in the nfl except for the oakland
raiders however it is frowned upon and
so that was their way of being like
don't let us catch you there's a couple
of things i've seen nfl players do that
i frown upon also should we talk about
those right right right so i did it for
that one year
went to the super bowl moved to la and
my first job was being an extra on
friends and so i got to do that for
season 9 and 10 loved every minute of it
i got to take free class from them watch
and learn
and soak it all up and so i think
because of that that's how i started it
it's
always been my dream as a multi-cam
sitcom like if i could just get my
multi-cam sitcom like that is my dream
world and i remember writing
bringing back to you know comparing
ourselves to others and stuff i remember
right right right right right right
right which might just say something
that changed my life when someone said
compare to me and program comparison is
the worst form of violence against
yourself ooh so as soon as you hear one
thing it might sound like a platitude
yeah but like
if you just hear it at the right time
you're like whoa i'm just cutting myself
a little less severe okay a little less
severe is comparison is the thief of joy
yeah
that's what i tell myself instead of
comparison
yourself
[Laughter]
i've heard the comparison is the thief
of all joy and that's what but that is
very interesting i don't i don't i don't
think that stealing is always bad the
thievery is sometimes good sometimes you
got to steal like sometimes people don't
deserve to have what they have but
you're stealing your own joints yeah
yeah but i never had joy so
i'm now implying that i had like joy
i never had joy to steal but i can
yeah don't
her middle name is joy like that you
have a vested you have an agenda with
this guy
that's why she's trying to push her
merch
she's trying to make a slogan for
herself over there she's trying to build
a brand and go for you yeah we love that
phrase we'll put on a shirt um but yeah
i need to hear things in a really savage
way yeah so anyway but please um
uh
keep going on
what you were going on so um oh
cheerleaders
yeah so after
raiders i moved to l.a started but what
did you learn from friends like what
were you like i'm gonna do that or i'm
gonna
honestly watching how they talk to each
other how they talk to the crew how the
writers would come on the set afterwards
and punch things up everything from um
just words that i didn't know like
finding your mark like things i didn't
know anything like i was brand new i
didn't know anything so i'm like taking
in all of this information
soaking it all up watching pros that are
respectful because you could have gotten
a toxic set they were the highest paid
actors on television at the time it was
the number one show on television at the
time and i got to be an extra and just
literally just watch and learn and and
soak it all up and so um
i've always had this dream of like oh my
multicam sitcom like that's what i want
and like just
writing it in my journal
where they're like did you have like
your show growing up like were you like
a mad about you person or george lopez
show i mean i loved uh i mean i loved
three's company best i loved um
i mean all the family ones like family
matters family ties martin was a big one
the step the uh step by step step by
step
um oh yeah martin for sure who's the
boss oh my god who's the boss angela
hello yeah i was like
a comedian a friend of mine um used to
do this joke like 12 years ago he was he
goes um i went to a um bruce springsteen
concert and tony danza was in the front
row and i was like damn who's the boss
it is just like a perfect joke so i need
to talk to you guys about something
which is that
you know i'm right
don't get defensive
you don't floss you don't
you can lie to me you can lie to
yourself
but we both know you don't floss
let's just be honest and if you think
you're floss you're flossing wrong you
are
i floss let's be honest
i'm gonna be honest
up until a couple months ago
i every time i flossed
hemorrhaging i mean full-on yeah yeah
halloween costume level
blood
bright red just blood
cocoa floss cocoa floss delivers
superior floss the softest and most
cleansing dental floss to protect smiles
hold strong super cleansing and breath
freshening more than 500 textured
interwoven filaments giving it a maximal
surface area to snatch plaque and degree
from between your teeth and gums leaving
you kissably fresh i love cocoa floss
and i didn't even know about all the
filaments but they work great avoid mask
breath by flossing daily go to coco
floss dot me slash whitney to get twenty
percent off the four spool set and free
shipping that's c-o-c-o-f-l-o-s-s-m-e
whitney and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout all
orders over twenty dollars ship free in
the us
don't be a dope floss
whitney left um so
my dream has finally come true
um and now i'd like to talk uh now that
i have my own show i'm gonna talk about
my favorite subject rothy's if you don't
want to choose between comfort and style
pick rothy's you may have heard of the
point and the flat from rothys but they
also make insanely comfortable sneakers
loafers ankle boots and more the best
part is everything rothys makes is
better for the planet they've repurposed
millions of water bottles into their
signature thread that goes into every
single one of their products that's why
i'm drinking this plastic bottle because
i know it's going to end up on my feet
one day
normally we drink um
not plastic i'm going to keep this one
for a long time get both style and
comfort this spring with rockies plus
get 20 off your first purchase at
rothys.com whitney that's r o t h y s
dot com slash whitney now back to our
guest and maybe whitney too
there's ebbs and flows to our careers to
our craft to
our wins to our losses and sometimes
it's your season to ride high which is
what was happening for me in 2007 2008
2009 when all that was happening the
nail salon video the mad tv the you know
alvin the chipmunks and all that was
happening and that was my season to ride
high and then in the same way like the
stars move and the moon moves and the
next thing you know now you're kind of
on the on the descend and by the way
thank god because
the best way
i believe an entertainer should be in
your life is
oh my god
her thing just came i haven't seen her
in a minute i haven't seen him in a
minute you know when like you're you're
you're missing the person a little bit
and that's what freaks me out a little
bit about podcasts sometimes where it's
like if you want to overdose on me you
can
and if someone is
listening to three hours of podcasting a
week why are they going to go come see
me live you just like i've seen i've i'm
with her every day yeah the car like i
actually need to get she's in my town
now yeah you know
i don't need to see her docking me i
don't need to see her do stand up
because all i do is hear her talk about
how horrible
anyway touch me
do you know what i'm saying so it's like
i'm like we have to also
uh comedy is fashion and we have to sort
of like play this game i mean robert
green talks about it like
in the art of deduction is this skilled
dance between uh you know being
available and being mysterious and also
we're artists which i know that word is
dorky but like you have to go away and
grow you have to like i'm like
after the last couple specials
i did i i did feel like i was like how
come i'm not doing things how come i'm
not on this show how come this pilot
isn't going and i was like oh i'm going
away so that i can grow as a person so i
have more i didn't have anything else to
say see you're lucky that you got that
note to yourself because i went through
a season like i was riding high and then
i started just like going away
but i didn't have that awareness of the
oh now she's just choosing to go away
right now
no one is like ooh she's cold they're
like and she's gonna like take time off
and turn stuff down that's what sure
sure and then my whole thing is like oh
man i was hot for a second i'm not hot
anymore like oh what's happening like
that
sort of you're incubating yeah
now i'm aware after the fact you know
after i spent all those years of being
like what's wrong with me nobody likes
me anymore like all the things instead
of being at a place where i can embrace
and be like oh this is my season that
i'm supposed to be in i gotta ride low i
gotta work on me i gotta evolve as a
woman and you fall i gotta deconstruct
some things i gotta do all these things
and by the way
joan rivers enter talking um she talks
about that a lot really elegantly and
about how like you know because we got
this programming that as a woman you
know my favorite shows the comeback uh
which is i think the best way describing
that you know in our business women at
four i mean i started getting offers for
mom roles when i was like 27.
you know like it was like i was the mom
now it's like i have no maternal
instincts all i do is make jokes
about
aborting children how am i getting these
offers this is crazy you know that's how
much of a mom i am now according to you
guys because i'm 27. yeah but that we
had this programming and then high def
television came along and that was a
real setback
that was our real setback oh my gosh and
then uh it just magnify i mean magnified
you know every wrinkle on your face and
then um but
my heroes are running dangerfield and
joan and people that like we get as
comedians once we put the ten thousand
hours in is around this time like this
is when we are at our greatest like
think about all your heroes that are
comedians like amount everything you've
done now
now it's like with the wisdom that only
comes with age with all that 10 000
hours on stage like we're just getting
great when they say uh youth is wasted
on the young that is nev that is so true
whoever says that doesn't know about my
dermatologist
it is man if i had this wisdom when i
was young jesus but but it's the wisdom
that only comes with age exactly i think
even if we had access to all this like
we had to learn the hard way yeah yeah
yeah yeah definitely i mean
i you know how much worse it would have
been if you're friends with comedians
that's god
thank god i had no friends oh man
and it's crazy because when we're young
and we don't have the wisdom that we
have now like when i go back and i'll
read an old journal and see things that
i was struggling with at the time that i
was you know debating about that i was
dreaming for and hoping for
and like my prayers and and i have
stacks and stacks of journals and i can
go through these and
sometimes i'm like thank god i didn't
get that thank god i never dated that
guy thank god we broke up oh my god
dodged like all the things but when
you're in it in the moment and you're
young and that's all you can see here
and think and so it's interesting how my
journals have progressed now and and
where i'm at in my life today but i
almost threw myself in front of a car
when i was 22 because i didn't get a vh1
pilot
in real real life
i was like it was like emily
i mean i'm being dramatic but i remember
being like like it wasn't me i just
stepped in front of this car right now
but i wouldn't talk about a network
about a game plan
okay that's a theovonne story um where i
ran into theovan once in uh an airport
you know when you like i love you know
when you run into a comedian in the
airport yeah and it's just like even if
we don't know each other there's just
something like hey we're both doing this
grind and like
we're both zombies and and you know and
i've known theo
for a while just when people are like
asked about what theo's like like this
is just theo in a nutshell
we had done tons of colleges together
probably knew him for five five years
and
if you see a comment you know in the
airport it's just like yeah it's just
like
everyone reacts like where are you going
where are you just oh shit you want a
punch line i was just like it's just
yeah yeah there's like a hundred of us
that can have this these co inside
conversations that no one knows
no one else understands what we're
saying
if i didn't stutter i could you could
even understand what i said yeah um but
i'm trying to tell this quickly because
i want to get back to um what you're
saying so i sit down
and you know there's like chairs up
against each other
theo is like his back is here like his
rat tail is here
his rack's kind of dipping into your
seat
i feel a rat tail on my shoulder
and yeah
um instant orgasm and
i see him like theo and he's like it's
like five in the morning yeah we're in
like charlotte it's some weird gate
that's like a little pl it's like you
know
and he just he he he literally without
missing me just looks at me and he goes
hey
looks up at the tv and just goes
vh1
talk about a network without a game plan
not like hey
where are you coming from do you
recognize you yeah i mean i think
like
but if he didn't know it was me why
would he talk it was like
it was just that's just theo in a
nutshell and i look back and i'm like oh
my god what if i had gotten that mm-hmm
and i was on a i was on a vh1 show
forever you know what i mean
and they had no game plan oh yeah
you know what i mean so it was like i
didn't know yet rejections god's
protection and like as a comedian i love
the wisdom that comes with age because i
now when something bad happens to me two
of like fault i have like it's like kink
it's like oh dude i'm gonna get the best
story out of this like i'm gonna get
because the first time i got a car i
filled uh i got my own car it was a
hybrid and i filled it with diesel fuel
the first day no bitch
[Laughter]
i pulled up
the nozzle there was a
two black ones this is a new car i need
the best one no there was one that was
the one by itself it wasn't
expensive enough no it was
it was green
and i was like oh hello
nozzle it's like good for the
environment this is like the good
oil
and then
i and
so this is probably it and then i go to
and then people like
the nozzle doesn't fit
and i'm like
i have like a new car they don't have
the new nozzle
like they're not even i'm so ahead of
these fucking dinosaurs
so i'm just gonna hold it up like i was
supporting i can't you cannot stop me
from doing this like no red flags or
obstacles are going to stop me from
doing this and then this is like right
by the comedy store that one on halloway
and whatever and it's a good glue and
i'm like music i'm like full i'm like i
got your water falling off you guys you
guys gotta get the new nozzles man like
i'm literally like do i do a yellow
review like this is annoying this is
dangerous you guys like what if someone
smokes like this could start and then
the car like the thing doesn't go it's
like it's like not going i'm like bring
a new car of course of course that's
what happened to me i got a lemon
and uh
and then it was
when i they had to tow the car in to the
lexus dealership
and i had done something alexis to the
gaming deal the men that worked there
were like
visibly like upset like
like the the the repairmen and the
like they were it like hurt their hearts
to see and they were like how long did
you drive on this or like
like it was like i had done something
horrible to a child like they were
just watching this beautiful machine
just get destroyed i told that story my
uh first special and i was like if i
hadn't had that horrible thing happen i
would have had that story
and now every time something bad happens
to the point to where like i'll go to
the flight i'm like i hope this gets
canceled like then i'll get it i hold my
luggage what if my luggage didn't make
it like i'd have a good job you know
like i think that because we're able to
alchemize and sublimate sort of the
bad things that happened to us into
entertainment i think we got a little
lucky in that sure regard sure um
the sting is definitely still there yeah
rejection we yeah we filter it
differently yeah yeah we place it in in
different places um
even i'm on prozac even most uh recently
uh
last year i was up for a really big
project and
one was called rust to get you to be the
cinematographer i hate you a lot
um
it was
i'm sorry i'm sorry
that's such a funny
like
decision that my middle name is
that is so
funny
anthony bethany johnson
is that your middle name
um okay this big project
i was up for it but
one to allow yourself
to get to a place where you get your
hopes up where you let yourself hope for
something
because you fight it you're like ah like
you want to manifest it but at the same
time you don't be disappointed because
if i acknowledge i'm i need to manage my
expectations so i don't get hurt but if
i manage my expectations i'm not 100
going for it and putting myself in the
arena and take it like you have to go no
i'm getting this yeah something that i i
wrote about was that i i'm the queen of
changing my perspective
being like okay you didn't book it but
at least you're in these conversations
at least so and so knows about
at least so and so did it
and
it was one of those moments where i was
like um
i want a win that's a win from all
angles but i don't have to manipulate
you can also
over
therapize or over gratitude you know you
can go like
well at least i got the hat no i
deserved it i want it yeah and i'm
annoyed yeah and i need to hold on to
this feeling because i want to win
and next time i'm going to win because
there is the only problem with our the
only problem with our business what uh
you guys there's one problem one there's
one
problem with hollywood um note which is
that a lot of it is just fucking unfair
and then it's a crap shoot it's like you
can only control so much and then it's
like
like
you know
you reminded the producer of his ex-wife
or the role went away or they couldn't
afford you because you were in the wrong
country or they needed a high local hire
or there was a union there's so much
that's out of your control
but
i think now is our time to not be
it's the time of the underdog it's the
time to not be the one that's like well
i came in second
that's pretty cool i never thought i'd
get here it's like no no bitch i'm gonna
come in first but a lot of times coming
in first means creating your own stuff i
mean reese witherspoon has to make her
own stuff mm-hmm jenny asked it has to
produce her own stuff i need to learn
how to do i need to learn how to produce
my own stuff how to write my own stuff
like i can write my stand up all day
long yeah um
anyway so
uh this project that i was up for is um
the new holiday movie with will ferrell
ryan reynolds yeah um
about uh you know christmas ghost of
christmas past present future mm-hmm
they called me about playing the ghost
yeah so me too
i looked too old and i was too pale
you're too accurate were you up for the
ghost was it really i was uh up for uh
the christmas past ghost of christmas
past or ghost of christmas present i
forget which one
um
but
it's a musical
there's dancing there's singing
all the things i got you
got you what are you what do you need
from me
and um the director loved me really
wanted me for this project and like we
got on a zoom call for like two hours
worked through all the sides it was
amazing had such a great time
um
i do side note i do find that um because
i am sassy yeah that um
sometimes people like ask for that
because it's funny and they laugh but
it's not the right choice for the
character yeah you know yes
and um so that's kind of what happened
in that first audition and i was like oh
man this is going
down a bunk weekly route and i really
don't want to do that but it's but why
don't i get the job and then have a
conversation with them that's what i'm
saying so i'm like okay and and i
remember him asking like are you okay
with this choice and i was like are you
okay with it well i know you're like so
disagree with you so once you give me
the job then we can have this
conversation do you like what you're
saying and he's like yeah i think it's
hilarious great we'll go with that you
know what i mean because you know
because you know i can't bring it up
right now you don't know that then
you know then it's like a whole thing
actually we went a little too far let's
do it again i was like yeah thank god
because i didn't want that either and
then but he really wanted me for this
role and he was like listen you're the
only person i see for the troll i this
is it i'm writing by the way don't tell
me that until
the contra don't don't tell me that
unless all the adjustments that i'm
making is with your voice in mind like
all the things right yep
and
i
go
in like
full manifestation full
all the meditations all the journaling
she almost killed herself to become a
ghost let me tell you
doing some inner child work flying
spirit airlines oh my god
i went through like
a lot i did a lot of processing in this
three months that i was up for this role
because i was i allowed myself for the
first time in a very long time to want
something
so i made myself vulnerable i had to do
a lot of self work to make myself
vulnerable
and you guys wonder why actors overdose
in a hotel room yes it's is so i'm doing
all this work to make myself vulnerable
and to remind myself that i have heard
yes before i have had a win before i'm
trying to do all that like self-talk
like you you are valuable you are worth
it you are you do deserve a seat at the
table like all these things right and so
for three months i fully believed i
could see myself
in in the billboard i could see myself
in the movie i was like this is mine i
know it is and then every time i would
get on an audition it was like okay
we you know we got some notes blah blah
blah let's do this okay great and then
i'm like what do you need you want me to
try something different he's like no
like trust me i want you for the
shoulder whatever then it gets down to
um
okay listen i want you for this role but
i have to convince
a lot of other people and right now
they're not convinced
so i don't know how many times audition
for this also there is such a thing
as not telling me any of that
you know what i'm saying so there's such
a thing as too much information
sometimes i feel like in that moment
though it really fed my
confidence yeah underdog that's what i
fucking that's my shit you know
and um beating the odds is what i do
i was on hold for this movie for like
three and then keep in mind
like
i have a stand-up i was gonna say you're
don't even if you gave updates for the
list no no no
i didn't but i i was fully manifesting
it being like let's not plan anything
because um uh it seems like i'm gonna be
filming there's a couple people that um
know nothing about comedy that went to
law school who were waiting on their
approval of me uh there's tens of
thousands of people that uh
have already paid money to hear me talk
that are sold on me so i'm gonna need
you to give me an answer yeah yeah yeah
so
um basically the story ends with um the
studio said no to me
name the person
who i don't even know who bitch who
i i have no idea but
they
let me they didn't get it
a lot of times these conversations
like uh pat we lost the tv
a lot of times these conversations
whittle down to that and having been in
these rooms so much when it's like oh
we're gonna go this way because this
person is a disney star who has
500 million followers in
you know china and india and then we you
know there's all these things where it's
like
they can't admit that's why they made
that decision
because that would admit that they're
not artists and doing it for the right
reason and then it gets distilled to
like oh it just she wasn't right for the
part and you're like i'm i'm sure that
is not how that conversation went down
and like you know in casting two bro
girls it was i i feel like hillary when
she was on the podcast she brought it up
but it was hilary duff two other very
famous blonde
actresses that had huge followings and
then beth bears who
had
her only credit was an independent movie
well she had been in the american pie
spin-off as like a
bartender number two and she won like a
peach pie contest in like a pageant at a
like
like in like like rural yeah it was like
on her resume like yeah like winner like
peach pie pageants
like best fancy walk or something like
something crazy
and she came in and she was the first
one i did we i mean
thousands i mean we saw thousands of
people and like the pressure of like
this is the person that she just had
that
it was very important that although all
the actresses that auditioned were
excellent and we should be so lucky to
have hillary duff
hillary duff coming out and being like
i'm broke it just was like
we felt very strongly that it needed to
be someone you didn't know that was just
sort of this like alien yeah opposed to
like oh there's that girl that i love
from that other thing
that i know isn't bro you know
it was just like we're in trying to make
a multicam
be less fake which by the way there's no
ceiling and everything's fake yeah you
know i mean the purses don't have the
the doors don't have locks on them and
there's no keys in anyone's part like
and just trying to ground that and have
this like unknown because you know tv
makes stars it doesn't stars on going on
except for this new streaming thing
it used to be that tv did not um stars
didn't make tv tv made stars so friends
cast pretty unknown like all those
and so the conversations were not who's
the best the conversations because it is
a business is well this person can get
talk show appearances they can get press
they can get on letterman they can go to
china and get you know uh do press over
there and you know that is the
conversation and then it whittles down
to you weren't right for the part at
least tell the actor
like treat them like equals and go hey
we're going with some and that's i have
no idea what happened with this movie
obviously and lee daniels actually he i
saw him do this once in an audition when
we were making that uh show for amazon
and it actually i had a pan i i
almost puked when i saw it happen
but i realized it was the most humane
thing someone came in i bet i could
josie tota ended up getting the part but
an actress came in and i if i looked at
the sheet i'd remember who it was but i
like started disassociating because she
gave an incredible audition and he went
that was incredible
you're not getting this job
and i will work with you again somehow
you're not right for this but that was
excellent and he's like i don't want you
leaving here having given an incredible
audition oh if i could hear and me
saying and i'm like
like i that's like my nightmare right
i'm like oh god no we have to pretend
we're gonna give it to her because she
did such a good job and then waste a
week of her life thinking she got it and
then avoid eye contact with her for the
rest of time you know like it was like i
would love to hear that conversation and
then she's going to hear from her agent
you did amazing you did amazing and then
it went they went in another direction
but
so he was like you're incredible i know
your name we're going to work together
again i'm going to write something for
you wow but you're not getting this job
and i don't want you getting the car
going i fucking nailed that because you
did and then spending time yeah hating
yourself thank you like
thank you
like knowing the level you got to at
that project like something else was
going on yeah yeah yeah i mean
if you if the director wanted you that
bad and the studio executive didn't get
it those two people shouldn't be working
together
on anything i feel like um
[Music]
i feel like i'm still very new
even though i've been in this industry
for a long time i'm talking too much but
i just don't think you have to take on
the i haven't learned about this
business and that's a disadvantage to me
because
if you knew more about it you probably
would have quit a while back and just
gone to make soap in new mexico
that sounds really good this is i cannot
be right with god and operate in this
cesspool uh
but but yeah so
that's that yes in my brain i do want to
go like but holy fuck you like almost
got that but now it's like it's time to
get it but
it's also time to like
and i know that this is not this is
going to sound
shitty as i say i don't like singing but
all those moments
if we like write your movie
because people are just waiting for it
let me tell you mom who is this
i've been married for 11 years and i
think for the past 10 of those years my
husband has been saying write your own
stuff and i'm like i'm not a writer but
i don't know how to write scripts by the
way have you read scripts writers not
writers have you read them what's the
time we read a good one it doesn't have
to be good
someone else will help you you know i'm
saying just something yeah you telling
one story is more interesting than most
movies
most movies are just copies of other
movies that writers don't know how to
most writers don't know how to write so
why not you and also just go like you
know with uh uh you know you know
there's gonna be more than just judd
apatow who's gonna like take comedians
and help them make sure you know what i
mean it's like he only has so many hours
in a day yeah yeah but like just get it
have you read save the cat no so read
save the cat and just start putting your
stuff on you've got 50 movies in you and
your perfectionism is just stopping you
that's all and
they'll go get a finance from todd
garner and you'll if burt kreicher can
start a movie you can star in your own
movie
okay
if they can get burnt krishna
i kind of feel like i mean he can't
spell
so
if you can't write he can't see his
computer key under his belly because you
know
so um
and then you know al madrigal yeah alan
madrigal is like
very uh you know they started a company
um
al magical and bill burr they produced
my last special they're producing a
bunch of podcasts like they kind of just
were like they started this thing called
all things comedy where they were like
should we talk about comedians like
having health insurance or a union or
like how do we help comedians that the
industry just doesn't get yet
or
that deserve to be have platforms but
like
they just you know yeah
you know
think
politicians eat babies and you can't say
that on main platform whatever you know
and he is very passionate about i
believe he did a comic book because he's
trying to do the first uh latin
superhero yeah and he's trying to just
make movies because he's like why isn't
nobody making movies in hollywood for
his painting people yeah this is crazy
uh i love owl i uh
i was cast to play his wife in a pilot
and then i got recast
i remember getting that call it was the
um hey the pilot got picked up
but you didn't they're recasting you oh
been there
love that part love that part yeah but
no i love owl yeah and where is that
what was the show called uh that was
about a boy
oh
minnie driver mm-hmm mm-hmm
yeah
it was it was the same i feel like you
won that round there was um
i remember that year i was up
before uh brooklyn nine-nine and i
remember i read the script and i was
like oh my god this is up my alley
for um the two latino roles now melissa
and stephanie
so um
i was like oh my god it's a silly cop
comedy like that is my jam i love crime
shows i love comedy let's do this yeah
and i thought the script was hilarious i
was like oh my god i want this they're
like okay they want to test you for two
rolls i'm like oh shit about to book one
you know what i mean like when did you
get to test for two rolls like and i
remember going into two of my running
fox was honey
tell penguins in pittsburgh they need to
call someone else because i'm working
okay i remember going into that audition
room and seeing the other girls and
being so confident like oh you're just
testing for one roll okay that's fine
don't worry your time will come don't
worry
watch and learn right exactly and just
walking out there be like i wonder which
one i'll get like that was my my my tude
was i wonder which one i'm gonna be the
one that uh dates uh
uh
yeah which one am i gonna get and
they're like hey
uh they went in another direction okay
for which role both of them oh cuckoo
cool okay sounds good sounds good and
then that same year i booked about a boy
and i remember my whole team at the time
was like you got the right one though
everybody's talking about about a boy
and then that one went away after season
no we're hollywood we're just talking
about boys yeah and then it's a brooklyn
night forever which i loved brooklyn
lanai i watched the show and i love
downstairs yeah man i yeah i would have
loved to have been on this show but
but yours is yours what's mine is mine
your journey your journey and we like
you know
what's the quote in the back of my book
in the end only three things matter how
much you loved how genuinely you lived
how gracefully you let go of things not
meant for you hmm yes as she just gets
up and leaves um
like how when when something isn't meant
for us how are we gonna it's like let go
or be dragged right am i gonna let go or
mine or just be dragged by this yeah but
to me it's like this is the most
exciting shit to me because you're in
that point where you're like i deserve
all this shit and the universe is like
no bitch you need to be writing your own
you need to be will ferrell in that
movie
you're not ghost number four
because that's because by the way then
you book it
and then
a pandemic happens
and production shuts down and then it
comes out i don't think this will be the
case
bad reviews no one sees it it comes out
on a weekend where i mean my book came
out the day of the vegas shooting
i was like yeah i know i was the real
victim in that scenario um
but it was like you you're like you get
it and you get it and then it's like
or it comes out and your scenes are cut
or your favorite takes are gone yeah
yeah there's just always gonna be if
you're not in control yeah there's
always gonna be
that
then you get it and you're like well
when's the shoe gonna drop yeah you know
what i mean yeah as soon as i get good
news i'm like uh who's going to die or
by the way you work i know you do i love
that's going to die i just booked
something because i have too many good
things because then you work on the
scenes for three months and you're ready
and you get there and they do a rewrite
and you're like oh i just worked now i'm
cold reading a movie with like
something's gonna happen that's just you
know so i think the universe is going
like
this is your time use this energy yeah
to write your movie
and then
they'll have to put you in the sequel
yeah yeah and then now people will know
if you don't book us i'll talk shit
about you
it's called leverage okay yeah white men
used to have leverage now white women
have it for probably a couple more
months so i'm just gonna use it for as
long as i can um okay i'm just gonna
have to have faith that i will be able
to get you for round two
yes because i i will keep you here
forever but we'll both get utis yeah and
that was the thing we did in our
twenties and not now also i have been
listening to your podcast angela oh and
as someone that
like
as someone that does not believe that
relationship advice one size fits all
like listening to it it's so it's like
chris rockwell said the more specific
you are the more general you are
i was sort of like
when i hear you guys talking about you
talk through relationship advice you
talk
you talk through shit that eve i get
uncomfortable sometimes i'm like this is
a real
they're really doing this this isn't
bullshit like it's you feel real
thank you resentments you feel real
problems being worked out in real time
yeah yeah manny would love if i was more
honest and open uh about a relationship
like i'm the one that's reserved and
we'll start he'll be like babe let's
talk about the argument we got yesterday
and i'm like
i feel like you're just taking fights so
we have podcasts like
i still figured out how i feel about it
myself the argument we had yesterday
we're still having
yeah what do you mean the argument i'm
sorry you mean the divorce yeah yeah
yeah yeah you want to record a signing
paper
what do you mean
what is it just you wanna have the judge
just come here zoom yeah yeah give
everyone the link but it's like it's it
really is like in and
it's about staying in the ring and i
think today we all have so many
opportunities to just call it and go on
tinder it used to be there was like five
people in your town you could date and
marry and you had to kind of stick with
them now yeah i can go on tinder right
now and find any number of couples
looking for a third uh
yeah so like there's so many
opportunities to just go like this is
too hard i'm out and so many people do
give up and so many people do get
divorced and you're like well half of
the men anyway why don't i just call it
now it's like
just it made me really
give up a lot of my immature
stories about
commitment
in marriage
well thank you i'm just now adding in my
married name after 11 years this is my
first time using my married name it's
wild i know you can legally change it
yeah i legally changed it 11 years ago
but not for brand wise i just stayed
angela johnson so this is my first tour
of the who
people just figured out how to spell it
you can't change it now exactly so now i
added you know what my my insta was i
was like if eva longoria can do it and
she's like uber famous then i could do
it too like eva longoria parker when she
was parker yeah
like i'm like if she can do it yeah i
can do it yeah kelly coco did it when
then she took it off after they broke it
was on kevin hart billboard and then it
was you know it's still
11 years later here i am did you get on
did you ever think about merging your
names a lot of people i know are merging
it into a new last name no no
it's not even a real thing
what it is
so that people a lot of like women i
know i are like well we'll just take our
names and make it like brangelina like
what's uh what's your last name
roach
okay so if we got married we'd be come
roach
we'd have a new last name the problem is
the guy i'm dating his last name is
barnes so we'd be cum barn so i can't do
it but a lot of people i know are doing
that and i have a couple friends that
have been married uh uh my twin in
portland who changed her name and now is
going back to her she's like i'm still
married i just want to go back to my
other name yeah oh i would be so
insecure yeah i'd be like wait yeah oh
no i just now no baby no no i just don't
want i don't want anyone to know we're
married yeah but i'm here i love you
yeah i just don't want anyone to know
i'm married to you is that weird
um off topic though but your twin is the
craziest twin situation i've ever seen
she would tell me she's like your fans
are so nice they came up to me like they
think i'm whenever they she gets
mistaken for me a lot one of my favorite
compliments when i leave a comedy club
is
hearing the wait staff say things like i
love when you come
your fans are the best your fans are so
nice they tip well yeah they drink they
buy food like i love and i love seeing
them count their tips and like they're
in a good mood yeah yeah like i that too
they're not trying to invest
they don't give us monopoly money yeah
they don't rush out yeah yeah that's
cool it was nick schwartz and told the
funniest story like he knows his fa
because his fans were a lot of like
college kids and he talked about
drinking and doing you know it's just
like yeah you know they're not bad
people they just like to party
and he did this venue where um it was
like you know sometimes we'll do like a
music hall or an opera house or like a
like a place where normally there's like
plays or something and uh he said he was
like this place is what do you guys
normally do here and they're like oh we
just had the lion king for four months
or something and he's like okay ah like
is there like security here and he's
like oh yeah over here and it's these
like old women that are like ushers yeah
okay and he's like
i'm just warning you my crowd is like a
little wild and they're like we got it
no problem we can handle we've had kids
here to see lion king like we can handle
this yeah yeah and then after the show
he said
we got it the manager comes up to him
um
we found two girls
passed down the bathroom someone is
sleeping
but yeah i think yeah it's it's
i we have so much more to talk about
so much more but we have to i mean i
have so many questions i want to ask you
just offline just yeah i mean we can
record it too and you know what here's
the other thing
comedian i think part of the reason shit
just started to really hit the fan with
comedians is because the thing that
keeps comedians saying is comedians
talking to comedians in the hallway
because we can both relate to this thing
and go like
everyone doesn't hate us we're not all
getting canceled people still want like
we
are uniquely qualified only to
understand what we go through and
we started doing podcasts where we
started having those conversations to
for public consumption and we stopped
having them offline
and then shit started to fall apart and
i think that we have to now schedule
not podcast hangs because i'm just as
guilty as i'll be in the hallway talking
to a comedian and i'm like let's just do
this let's come let's do a package
tomorrow let's let's not waste this this
is such a good conversation
there's so much insight here
and then we only have it for this
and then we're like oh we can only hang
out on camera yeah which is
yeah yeah really toxic yeah i would love
to hang out with you not on camera and i
remember one time
a long time well you'll be in some
stories i mean we don't we're not gonna
go that we're not amish a long time ago
you and i went to lunch and when i said
a long time ago i'm in my 20s we're in
our 20s we're the same age so we're in
our 20s and i don't remember eating
lunch at all on my twenty
so i recommend it by the way
one you're both
and this is like again like being all
insecure about whatever like okay i'm
gonna go have lunch with whitney
cummings you know
and i'm like okay i'm gonna be real cool
and i was like i'm gonna tell her we
should go meet at this cafe
and it was not
i forget the name of it but it was the
um
the no the something cafe that's
basically the cheesecake factory it used
to be at the beverly center
at the bottom oh oh
and let me tell you i go oh let's meet
at the grand lux cabin like if you want
to go to vegas yeah in hollywood and
then you you started laughing and you're
all grand loves cafe
[Applause]
you know we're not going there and then
you took me to like toast or something
like super trendy super like hole in the
wall
like if you're lucky you'll see reese
witherspoon there like all the things i
was like oh yeah this is way better than
than grand lux cafe you're right it's
totally right great luxe cafe was it's
like i think it's like for tourists or
something but it was like you didn't you
live in pasadena at the time
yeah yeah okay it's like the kind of
thing that
like
it's it's i don't know how to explain it
because i sound so sh it's i sound like
such an asshole but it's more like the
grand lux it's like
for when like actors parents come into
play yeah yeah like it's like uh yeah
it's the choice cake back here it's
literally yes and i was just it is like
a buffet and it's like but also i was
probably i can't afford this like
it's an 80 buffet this is where like
sebastian would go if he had to stoop to
not having a private chef he would like
this is his type of thing like like
we're going for it it's very like vegas
ish
it's like that or like the rainforest
cafe yeah yeah it's like uh that's what
it felt it felt like oh my god i just
invited whitney coming to go the
reinforced cafe
which is like i was just like that's so
funny
i hope that didn't come off shitty
because i i used to i used to someone
took me there like a weird tinder date
or something like like i did have to go
there another time
and i'm like obsessed with the grand lux
cafe it's the same way like if people
ask me to hang out our lunch i'll be
like oh one saddle ranch like it's like
the dumb joke first thing which now the
salad ranch is like a jam but uh uh or
like jumbo's clown room it's like the
strip club we used to do comedy at or
i'd be like grand looks good like that's
the funniest place to go yeah i was
being serious i wasn't joking but that's
like that's the funniest way because
it's just so like
it's so mall of america right right
right you know what i mean and i
definitely didn't know let's go pay 12
for avocado toast because i have seven
dollars yeah yeah
is we should go to the buffet and put
all the fucking stuff out first
and eating for a week yeah you were
probably just trying to get those rolls
damn it
that is so funny sorry if that came off
bitchy no it's way fine i've just been
insecure about it for 11 years it's
totally fine
i missed that chapter in the book
no but also
yeah it's like we walk around the world
comedians were such bulls in china shops
and other comedians are sensitive and i
think we forget and i was i came from
roasting and at the time i was in a room
being like
like we just would
would play fight yeah yeah and sometimes
you play too hard with someone by
accident
and you're just being a bitch yeah yeah
yeah it took me a long time to realize
like 2 p.m on a tuesday lunch isn't
roast time yeah yeah like we're just
yeah yeah and i'm like you're gonna
order that food like just like yeah
everything's a joke yeah yeah yeah
you're ordering crabs don't you already
have them like you're just like
stop just stop
what are you doing no one's you're
learning do you know what i mean like i
just couldn't i thought if i thought of
something funny it had to come out of my
face
i think that's the thing that people
would always um get wrong about me is uh
which is a good somebody asked me this
what's something that people would you
know get wrong by this is it people
think that i'm always funny that i'm
always on and like people will ask
my husband or
my assistant or whoever and be like is
she always funny like does she say funny
things all the time and do you know
anything about comedians
like what do you see
no i i am so you're a doctor are you
always doing surgery that's what i'm
saying i love to like laugh at other
people and then i forget sometimes like
i'm doing interviews or things like that
and i'm like oh shit they expect me to
be funny think of a punchline hurry up
because i was just like being real i'm
the other way i go like
if you want to see my funny stuff go pay
for it go buy it go watch it in context
and then here i'm going to surprise you
with something else
so that i'm not wasting my funny shit on
your show yeah i'll put my funny shit in
my show yeah and i'm saying i'm here to
promote my thing and i think sometimes i
mean the most surprising thing a
comedian can do is just be
authentic and refreshing and insightful
because that's that's actually our job
yeah our job is to be funny but it's
like
you know george carlin and prior and all
the greats that we look to we're not
just we've never just been vapid clowns
mm-hmm
the good ones
chris rock like
you know he's also singing something
messed up you know what i'm saying so so
it's like
we can't not have pathos and it also
um
comedy the last thing i'll say i know i
have to shut up but i'm just so excited
to talk to you i know he's like shitting
in my lap
um and so
okay that was important that was
important that was important
huh chris rock but there was a
so close uh we're not clowns we're not
uh shit
um can you roll back the tape not
telling jokes all the time surgeons
don't do surgery
all the time
the dog's shitting in your life it's
been three hours i've gotta stop you
know what i'm gonna think of it yeah and
i'll have you come back we'd love to
just to pick up that one thought okay if
that's okay yeah if we just do some
reshoots later yeah yeah yeah um would
really appreciate that totally not i
know i think i'm having like a blood
sugar spike and i have to let you go um
okay book the tour i love you and i am
so obsessed with your podcast and i'm
actually so glad that we're picking up
now because i think that
had we been closer during the 20s
you would have seen a lot of stuff that
i'm not proud of and like you would have
it would i'm glad we're getting close
again at a time where i'm the woman i
want to be or closer to amen because
that's what you deserve same same here
friend i would have wasted a lot of your
time
same here yeah i i would have probably
tried to put my shame on you and i
couldn't and i would have taken it i
would happily i ate it for breakfast
that was the only yeah and i would have
turned it into a drug addiction so you
know it's i'm so glad that we're
reconnecting now because then we don't
have to be embarrassed about like
remember that time like we don't have to
we just get to and i'll be able to
actually show it for you and i can you
can actually rely on me thank you and
you wouldn't have been able to back then
i love you a lot and i would have just
been secretly jealous of you
and pretending
overcompensating by pretending i wasn't
i'd be sabotaging you yes before your
shows giving you extra drinks
before you should just just just listen
to
them
you have anxiety
yeah
i love you don't write elephants angela
johnson
reyes
[Music]
[Applause]